hey everyone it's sarah thread sterner
sorry and calm and today I'm going to
demonstrate how to find the temporal
pulse point and whenever you're
assessing the pulse you will be looking
at a few things one thing will be the
rate how fast is it along with the
strength and you'll be grading it on a
scale zero to three with zero being
absent one plus it's week two plus it's
normal and three plus its bounding and
then you'll want to look at the rhythm
is it regular or irregular and as you
fill on the pulse you will be filling
bilaterally to see if they're equal and
to find this artery you'll want to find
landmarks and this always goes for any
pulse point that you're trying to find
now this temporal artery comes off of
the external carotid and goes up and
what you want to do is you want to find
the tragus of the ear which is this part
of the ear and the zygomatic arch is
found above it which is a fancy way of
saying the cheekbone so your pulse site
where this X is is found right here this
is your temporal artery and you'll want
to feel bilaterally and see if they are
equal and the time that a nurse really
feels on this is during that head-to-toe
assessment when whenever we're assessing
the pulses in the head okay so that
wraps up this video on how to check the
temporal pulse point and don't forget to
check out our other videos on how to
assess other pulse points on the body
thank you so much for watching and don't
forget to subscribe to our channel for
more videos